il ya des jours où tu n'as pas envie de
jouer seul devant ton computer j'ai cru
que tu ailles anouk et a atteint
j'attends que ça se passe là pourquoi
vous mouiller devant le micro ordinateur
ils ont tout gâché j'avais peur d'être
coup ils ont tous blessés
aujourd'hui on est avec cyril yann et
mika bonjour et on va jouer au ou non ce
jeu auquel vous avez tous joué en
colonie de vacances que vous étiez bien
bien pu ce jusqu'au sang et ben on
retombe dessus aujourd'hui et
franchement c'est budgété préféré je
sais pas si tu as remarqué il est
vraiment bien ce jeu les amis préparez
vous à des game d'exception j'ai mis une
option accumulation parce que je trouve
ça très drôle c'est si tu te prends en
plus de mériter un + 2 et ben ça fait
plus 4 pour le mec qui joue après toi et
c'est l'option ils viendront est
d'accord avec moi je suis mort de rire
non là en vrai je vais pas vous mentir
les amis on sort d'une gaine qui a duré
20 minutes voilà servis n'a pas ce qu'on
a mis knock you quand tu peux pas jouer
tu pioche les cartes jusqu'à ce que tu
empêches une que tu peux jouer voilà
hélas si mon public ne connaît pas le ou
non les gars je suis foutu et on cherche
allez les gars que la gamme commence que
le meilleur gagne n'hésitez pas à voter
dans les commentaires comme ça ça me
fera du bon référencement pour la vidéo
on y va ok les gars c'est parti on passe
à la mêlée nous c'est exactement la même
carte j'ai vraiment jeune
allianz a dégagé un excédent
mika est ce que tu aimes les cartes way
home use beaucoup mais toi bien me tiens
au plat et je me dis aux jeunes des gens
pas vers la victoire
ok mais qu'à toi j'y croyais et hop là
c'est bon ça mais arrêtez [ __ ] c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe c'est
exceptionnel n'est pas fou du coup je
vais aller contrôler les gars qu'on
trouve au clic & click et je suis allé
moi merci jansson fait très plaisir tu
es un mika j'aimerais que tu pioche s'il
te plaît et je me fous pas une pleureuse
il bluffe et bada os c'est comme ma
gueule
samedi d'amitié c'est fini et c'est pas
parce que je la bonne
derrière ces rides et des complots dati
dans l'équipe bien sûr il attention
c'est serré c'est très serré hormis pour
mika qui va faire pioche et cyril dans
pas longtemps et les accoutrements
reprenait contre nos premiers à me
contrôler nos attaquants qui jouent
heil a pas de faire le con contre nos
sûr s'il y préparez vous en faites quoi
y'a ou une autre vous cliquez préparer
bouge pas compliqué mais on va y aller
oui non oui série jo thème tient vas-y
fais toi nos photos non ah bah non en
fait c'est pas fini j'ai plein de 4 mais
attention aux la contournant contre-don
oh non mais j'ai fait mais c'est comme
ça loin d'être mauvais ya pas deux pas
dont tu n'es pas là ça mais non mais pas
les menteurs et c'est sa voix de mme en
terre cuite agents mais c'est justement
si tu l'as tu peux pas pas non je n'ai
pas le plus grand gardien
ouah c'est ta vidéo je te laisse gagner
je veux dire normal aucun petit koala
revanche sur ta chaîne envers avec les
stations ou non ok c'est reparti ok un
calvaire à toi mika ben c'est pas un
bâtard [ __ ] à jallais m'enflammer
cyril c'est long à saly on va salir les
juges de quoi comme couleur du mois
bazire est un bleu ou vert ça m'arrange
avec il a ce qu'il faut à yan tu fermes
ta a laissé aller là-bas direct c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave les faibles et
faible
c'est un plus je dis ouais j'ai pas j'ai
pas chez moi j'ai qu'un seul jaune
merci allez allez olla n'est pas du tout
qui va prendre du coup j'ai donc si vous
voulez bien je vais changer un petit peu
le sens pour me pour la branche un petit
peu mais je voulais qu'ils gagnent parce
que j'ai il est nul à tous les jeux on
peut y laisser 0,7 point et je vous
emmerde
ok les gars de mes deux j'espère je pèse
1 kg avec cyril on est bien avec moi tu
as vu cyril je pourrais ponelle avec toi
tu me qu'est ce que cela allait me sens
pas d aller me sied pas y'a un truc qui
qui apparaît moi je clique [ __ ] j'ai
cliqué bandeau sainte-eugénie kébé de
couleur si je pourrai plus de poney à la
victoire
l'afutt a essayé tu plonges de la bonne
carte attention et conteste hier ouais
merci james bosh est de la merde
cyril je compte sur toi à la pression
oui ok charge la couleur
ok c'est parti avec qu'est ce que je
vais être attention tâche avec mika les
carcasses de syrte est bon ça ses rives
ouais mais maintenant il a un dilemme
puisque at il appuyé ska de la tâche
qu'elle ne compte pas laisser makes me
farthouat
mais attaquer et hop ok ok on va faire
pareil on ne peut pas excellent mais si
ça c'est pas le pied quoi yann j'aimais
envie de te suivre un petit peu le petit
fils de m attends attends ok ok pas de
souci il pas tout si ça marche c'est le
cas en chaîne c'est la sentence soit ils
ont mis ko tout envie il en a pas parlé
à l'émission va gagner mais qu'on va
gagner
regarde la couleur regarde la couleur
regard la couleur chaude chaude avec la
trop de cartes sim et une heure à la
regarder ça fout c'est risqué au nord au
nom c'est pas là mais qu'à ses calculs
et celle calculée mika et j'ai trois
cartes mikami car franchement on est
bien franchement on est bien voyager
mais qu'on ait gravir les graphiques
vas-y vas-y tu es tu m as perdu tu mets
ton interdite ac c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon ok on est bien on est bien on
est bien on est bien ou non je mets ça
qu'est ce que le bluff d'un marché
mickey oui il a du rouge oui j'ai des
rougiers du rouge
j'ai pas d'autre choix j'ai pas d'odeur
j'ai fait un bluff d'un bluff mauriac
question à faire
il a bluffé le bluff quoi j'ai bluffé le
bluff nerfs ça fait penser je vais
mettre les lunettes des joueurs de poker
voilà de même attention on est ensemble
c'est beau ce qui se passe parce que si
je jouais bien non je suis avec
l'ancêtre allez les gars faire un truc
l'équipe qui gagnent cela tend à tout
gagner face à son moi j'ai rien à perdre
j'ai tout perdu va gagner je les crois a
les y'a bon eh bien oui oui maintenant
pourquoi tu fais ça yan yan ou gap cela
va tout gagner ziri la pub de caa qui
nous arrive il n'a pas de bleus et de
draft bluecar série oui c'est bien on
n'oublie pas d'appuyer sur la bonne
couleur mais du bleu
je mets du verre yan tu veux gagner mais
bon on est mort on est marianne semble
aller battre ces petits as tu en prends
ton temps prend pas non non non non non
non non je fais moi confiance
j'aimais du verre on va faire de la
dernière
et bien malin qui tjp l'addiction va
jamais s'en sortir
eh ben les amis c'était une petite
partie de nos j'espère qu'elle vous a
plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à me
lâcher un pouce bleus tout en disant uno
bien évidemment autre couche bien zut il
vous a eu à l'adversaire et merci à
cyril bikaï a facilement la chaîne
youtube c'est des gars en or a très bien
supporté mon bien tiens tout le monde
j'ai fait la une où trouver la bonne
manière toujours plus fort toujours plus
vite
c'est quoi ça toujours plus loin